let's just do it
yeah
and
we doing it happy holidays here we go
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all weekend so
never got a chance to record my podcast
it's hard to do it on the road
so here we are
live monday morning on podcast monday
i'm gonna talk about kevin hart's show
true story succession
dexter and some electric car stuff but
once again welcome back
all right
welcome back to river with griffin
thank you for being here
excuse me but first first uh
where is it first i'm doing it you know
i'm here by myself again so i gotta do
all this by myself but first big shout
out today to helix sleep
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
find your perfect mattress at helix
sleep dot com
slash griffin
also
express
vpn
big tech is tracking your every move
online visit
expressvpn.com griffin that's express e
x p r e s s vpn dot com slash griffin to
get three extra months free with my
exclusive link
all right what's up everybody
um
excuse me man i had a sinus infection
and it's just messing with me my voice
is all messed up but you know it is what
it is i was nervous so i took like some
covet tests you know i had to do that
home covet test i took like three of
them just to be sure you know because
anytime you get sick now you think oh
man i
what is it you know but i won't forgot
that there's still other things in the
world that make you know that you can
actually get that have nothing to do
with
the big c word um but anyways
what's up y'all so
as you can see today's picture is a
picture of my living room or you know
near my living room because rachel's
jewish
and i'm not
and you know so we have a christmas tree
up with the happy hanukkah decoration
you know we got the little uh what is
that right there the uh
stockings so rachel's all into that i
think this is the first time she's had
her own christmas tree because again
she's jewish she grew up jewish so but
she likes christmas you know what i mean
like we we
we went to one year we went to costa
rica for christmas you know so we set up
we're going we gonna be celebrating
christmas because i celebrate christmas
but you know when you have somebody
special in your life
holidays kind of light up i mean as a
guy you know like your birthdays come
like when you like you get to your
mid-30s and your birthday comes as a
dude if you don't get nobody special in
your life you don't really care you're
just kind of like all right another year
you just kind of go you don't worry
about it and it's not until you get
somebody special in your life and then
they make your birthday special because
they're just like all right we're gonna
go do some things and boom especially
when you're in a relationship and it's
like heaven forbid
when you're in a relationship that you
don't want to do anything on your
birthday
because then it becomes about then she
gets mad she's like oh i was trying to
do this special for you and you're just
kind of like all right but then once you
do it you really feel good about it you
know you're sitting there and you're
like damn i'm so glad she made my
birthday special so it's the same thing
with holidays like last year i cooked a
thanksgiving turkey for the first time
ever in my entire life i got the recipe
i got the turkey i did all this stuff
and it turned out okay um
i think this year we're gonna do some
christmas dinner that we're gonna make
ourselves because i got my traeger grill
so i'm gonna smoke it smoke a turkey or
a chicken or something so you know now
i'm realizing like having somebody
special in your life makes things
special you know it makes it more it
makes it fun makes it interesting
especially i'm sure when you have kids
i'm sure you know if we have kids it's
going to be even more like oh this is
what it's about so
i'm starting to see that now in my like
later stage in life now you know
enjoying life more because of this uh
beautiful princess i have here with me
so happy hanukkah hannah could just pass
so we had to k we haven't have oh we
already have a little menorah over there
we you can't see it but it's on the on
the other side of the christmas tree so
we like lit you know we lit that every
night she had that going so you know i
don't know the traditions of it or
whatever but i believe in traditions so
for all you guys out there happy
hanukkah merry christmas happy holidays
for whatever you celebrate so it's that
type of year
so
that's what's going on in my living room
um
yeah so i was in um where was i i was in
uh
san diego this weekend uh at the la
jolla comedy store and man it was dope
man i had a really good time
oh look at me it was like a pack shows
all five shows were great i did two
shows on friday two shows saturday and
one show on sunday and they were all
packed so shout out to all the people in
la jolla and san diego area they came
out and saw me it was really good
weekend and this was a really great
crowd so it was fun
but
excuse me i'm gonna tell you about
all right so yeah i mean if you listen
to my podcast you know i have an
electric car i'm all about electric car
i believe that they're saying by 2 20 30
there's gonna be no gas cars that's
something i heard but i don't know but i
believe that that should be the way it
is
um you know it's like what's the point
of having a gas car you know what i mean
like the electric cars look good they
last long they're fast they're sleek you
know they finally figured it out
it's it's looking good electric cars are
great and they got more coming out every
single year every company is like okay
we'll make electric cars
you know but the problem
with having an electric car
is the infrastructure is not
it's not the best
if you ask me it's not the best so like
for instance
you know
and shout out to the chat i see you guys
right there so if you're listening live
if you're not listening live if you're
listening on spotify or whatever else
you're listening on apple music apple
podcast all that stuff you know thanks
for listening thanks for being a loyal
subscriber and a listener i appreciate
you and are you guys listening live
right now i'm seeing you in the chat
right now so it is
what it is but
so i do see you
um
so you know
no no i see people in the chat like some
people can't afford tesla's tesla's not
the only electric car man there actually
are a lot of affordable electric cars
hyundai makes one toyota
they're all they're actually there there
are some and even tesla makes a one of
the models that's like you know
a good price range you know what i mean
i mean cars are what they are man you
know they're going to be like in between
20 and 30 000 is gonna be like i think
the low end and if you can't afford they
can get something used you know but if
you're talking about a new car
i mean you know if you get trying to get
a new car so not all not every electric
car is a luck they have a lot of luxury
brands they do there are a lot of luxury
brand electric cars
but there are also some affordable ones
that they're coming out with too man you
know toyota ford they're all making
their cars and they have these hybrids
still
so you know look out for that but
anyways
now tesla has a good infrastructure in
place
because they got the supercharger things
all over the place and they're you know
they're there to make you know your life
easier if you own a tesla and then the
car has its thing where it'll tell you
where to go what to do now if you don't
have a tesla
it becomes a little it becomes harder
man you got like charge point and you
got all these different types of charge
things but you know what it's not
reliable it's not dependable so i have
an electric car and when i'm in la and
i'm driving around the city it's fine
you know like when i go from my place to
the comedy store to the lab factory to
the improv or even if i'm visiting my
parents out in oxnard which is like 50
miles away i can get there and back
drive around a little bit and i'm fine i
know i can get home i can charge
even at their place i know where the
charging places are but that's like what
i'm familiar with but when you're going
out of your comfort zone and say you're
like okay so for instance i went to san
diego
so i got my own hotel they reimbursed me
but i got a hotel and the first thing i
look for when i go to a hotel is
is there an electric charging station at
the hotel because then it makes it easy
you just plug in you're ready to go
whatever there's usually a minimal cost
or sometimes the hotels have one for
free
so i look up this one and they say they
have one when i get there it's like a
parking lot that's connected to other
businesses that's connected to the hotel
so this isn't exactly their electric
charging it's like semiconnect what i
think is the name of the company sema or
whatever it is
and it's a hassle you know what i mean
it's like you can only park for three
hours and then it's ten dollars and
hours after ten dollars an hour after
and i'm like this isn't cool like this
isn't like and so then it was and then i
get there and i'm literally like
my car is about to die
when i get to this hotel late at night
because i went late i had a show in l.a
and then i drove to san diego late
because i had to do radio in the morning
okay so i'm driving so i had like say
200 something miles on my car
san diego's like 100 miles away but
that's all a myth like like when you
have an electric car
and and they tell you the the amount of
miles you can go that ain't really true
it's never true because they don't count
in ac radio maybe you have your phone
plugged in all that stuff takes power
the radio and all that stuff takes power
so
you know i'm getting to san diego and i
got like 20 miles left on my on my uh
you know you know that i could go i get
to the hotel i'm down to like 15
actually and it was like oh man
it didn't work i was frustrated i went
inside and i was like yo man what's up
with this electric car that's the reason
why i picked this hotel
so now i got to go on the apps
and i find one it's a whole foods maybe
four miles away from where i was
so now i gotta like drive to this whole
foods and i have also
it has to work
one thing a good thing about the apps is
they do tell you like when you look on
the app
it's connected to the thing so it'll say
it's working or it's you know or
someone's using it or whatever so you
know that it's working you know so
because this is my last hope i mean i
get there and it's gonna be a situation
where i don't even know like i don't
even know what to do like i don't know
if you could call a tow truck and they
have a battery charger like i don't even
know how that [ __ ] works
so
i get to this whole food so now i gotta
sit here it's the middle of the night
and so i parked my car and it was like
what's the one um
charge no no what's i forgot the name of
this one evie go evie go is like a fast
charger so i know that i could sit here
for like 25 30 minutes and i'm gonna get
you know i'm gonna get 60 70 charge but
now i'm like it's the middle of nine i'm
sitting in a whole foods parking lot so
then there was like a mcdonald's across
the street so i just like parked the car
i did that and i went walking to the
mcdonald's and i'm like damn what i'm
like what am i doing like i got this
high-end electric car but i'm like doing
all this nonsense
so i don't know man i just hope that
when if they're going to say we're all
going to have electric cars then our
like the gas stations are going to
convert to like it's it's all going to
be fast charged like
it to me it makes no sense to have um
level 2 chargers anywhere in public like
anywhere in public to have a level two
charger is nonsense if you don't know
what that means it's like a level two
charger is like a low like 110 volt
i believe
or
yeah it's like it's a no no no it's like
a low voltage charge that it is usually
going to take most cars
six to eight hours to get a full charge
so like if you're in public let's say
you're going to the market and you plug
in
you know it's like what's the point of
that you're getting what three miles out
of that it's like whole foods thanks for
having free chargers but put the damn
fast charger in there so then you can
like get
you know you can use you're going to
whole foods for 20 minutes when you come
out you almost charge you know you got
100 miles out of that or something i
don't know
so
i mean
for all you guys out there iffy about
getting an electric car
you know you just got to like you really
got to plan things out
you got to plan it out like i have yet
to like think about driving my car to
vegas like i don't think i would do that
i just don't think i would do it because
my car only gets like 270 and it's not
270. you know like i already know that
like after a hundred something miles i
gotta charge for 30 minutes so it's one
of those things like do you want to do
that you know so that's the thing like
until the cars are like 500 miles where
you know you're going to get 300 miles
you know you of solid 300 miles
i don't know about driving across
country or doing it because it's like
you know it's the kind of thing where
it's like you got to stop it's not
convenient you know so that was my uh
situation i had this weekend and i was
like so can you guys know me i yeah i
was so frustrated you know
just like what the hell am i supposed to
do like what like what if i would have
like you know
lost the uh
the charge you know what i mean
so i don't know
um
[Music]
anyway
was there something up with my audio is
my audio now i hope the audio is
sounding good it is what it is i don't
know i don't know what to do i'm already
live i'm already recording so like you
know what i mean it is what it is
um
you know i don't know
so you know when you do it live this is
what you have to deal with so the people
that are listening later i mean i hope
it comes out good if not you know it is
what it is
[Music]
so
i don't know
um
you know listen i mean i know what
you're like you know i know what you're
saying like i don't know like yeah like
what's the like somebody just asked a
question what you think powers the
electric car stations like you know hey
who knows how these things work
i don't know but i don't think that like
it depends on what you
like what is overall better for the
environment or
i mean i don't know like actually
i know in california a lot in nevada
they have that big
solar power station
that's in between like going towards las
vegas they got that big power station
there
so i'm sure that you know the power is
being run by that but
uh
you know you know what i mean so i mean
i i don't know i mean
i just don't think that we need to have
like all these gas powered cars on the
in in the streets with all that
admissions
i'm sure that if you take away all of
the car emissions emissions that that's
going to be better for the environment
in itself even if you have some gas
powered
you know station far out that's like
powering all the electricity combined
with wind power and solar power
i'm sure that's better than
all these cars on the road with you know
with exhausts
you know and then you know there's other
things that they could do too because
you know like i see somebody saying that
there's natural gas there's um
there's hydrogen
hydrogen is that the one like you know
but there's no infrastructure in place
you know bmw had those cars but like
where do you go like where do you drive
to like how do you fill up you know so
you know i don't know i mean we're
the future is coming
the future is coming so we have to
figure this out
it's like i think that
i think that like you know having those
battery-powered houses and all that
stuff the the the solar panels on the
roofs and i just think that like they
should be everywhere you know like even
in apartment buildings they should have
solar power panels on the roofs that's
powering helping power like maybe just
your water heaters
just the the the
even if it's just powering the
the roof the um you know the
climate stuff
whatever like i remember going on a trip
to i was in costa rica and like every
bungalow we were staying in they had
like the solar panels was connected just
to the water heater and i thought well
this is a good idea you know
um you know but which is weird you know
is there somebody saying nuclear energy
is the future well it should have been
it's the most it's the cleanest energy
but you know
we we've had in history some of these
accidents that have happened that have
now scared us all to think that oh
that's what that's what can happen
but
so i don't know man
i'm not a scientist if there's any
scientists out there
uh you know oh and speaking of so last
week i had asked a question and i got a
really great response from like a doctor
so i'd ask the question about if
if um
you have an adverse reaction to the
vaccine would you also then have the
same reaction to covet itself
so the guy gave a great response to me
he was saying like i just paraphrased he
was saying like well there are some
things in the vaccine that say you could
possibly be allergic to so apparently um
what's his name aaron rodgers is
allergic to something in the vaccine
but but but at the same time the things
that are in the vaccine that are also
related to covid
then yes if it's those things and yes
you could you would have the somewhat
same reaction but there are other things
in the vaccine that are
you know
that are not
covid or whatever so i appreciated that
response so if anybody out there has
like you know if anybody's in the ga in
the natural gas electric electric
car any scientists out there what is
better
are we making the environment better if
we go all electric or is it the same
kind of thing you know
it's like because apparently they're
talking about like like the
crypto mining and all that stuff
apparently when you're you're doing like
the crypto mining and all that that's
using so much power and resources to
make that run like all the to keep
servers running and all this stuff and
maybe that there's another danger in
that so i don't know so you guys gotta
like let me know
out there if you uh
you know just because you know let them
know so
no no
the guy didn't have
he did a guy didn't have doctor in his
name they got they got he he gave a very
thoughtful
medical response and i appreciated his
response he's not like one of you troll
idiots who just like just like seeing
yourself be a dick on the screen that's
what i think some of you love to do you
just love to type something stupid and
then look at it and be like yeah
look what i did you know but whatever
okay um enough of that
that was great um let me talk about now
let's get into uh the things that i
wanted to talk about today i want to
talk about some shows that i've been
watching
some shows i've been watching
oh oh that's not this one wait what
uh get rid of that okay i'm doing this
all by myself no it's not just either
what is going on man here we go finally
all right so let's talk about this kevin
hart show
series it's a limited mini series i
think it was like
excuse me i think it was like eight
episodes it was called true story
there it is it's like kevin hart and
wesley snipes are the main guys in uh
this
billy zane he had a really great role
too
um so it's about kevin hart pretty much
playing like a kevin hart character he's
like this like superstar comedian
and
you know he has like you know
he has a brother played by wesley snipes
who's
like he's not the best guy you know what
i mean he's you know he's he's always in
trouble with the law he's always he
always needs money it's that kind of
story so and then kevin hart plays this
big time superstar comedian who's like a
big star he's like in like superhero
movies and you know he also had a drug
problem and he got over that and it's
about him and his team
uh you know
managing his life but like uh something
happens like there's a tragic sort of
event that happens and it's about the
whole series about is about how kevin
hart's character and his brother get
themselves out of this jam and then the
story unfolds and you find out what
happened why it happened how it happened
and who's at fault but it was actually
really good
i actually really enjoyed uh
i really enjoyed this and
it you see kevin hart in a completely
different light it was it was sort of
dramatic and serious it was like you
know as if you were seeing actually
kevin hart like when he was not on stage
you know what i mean so i thought it was
really good and i really enjoy
i like this format i like eight hours of
entertainment you know like this easily
could have been like just a movie that
we would saw it'd be a one-off it's done
um
i you know i i wish we you couldn't just
binge watch it i'm a fan of like waiting
a week like i like i am a fan of that i
think you it builds up anticipation and
i like that you know i like that and
then you can binge it all later you know
um but
excuse me this was this was really good
like it was really enjoyable and i like
how it ends like it like it ends on a
wow like you know what i mean you're
just like what
i can't believe you did that so i won't
spoil it you know how i like to spoil
stuff
but this was good i thought wesley
snipes was good i thought all the
characters in the in the movie were good
i thought i thought the guy that was
playing kevin hart's manager did a good
job like and he's trying to be his
handler and then he had this girl who
was like she was like you know his like
ghost writer
uh who was like you know there with him
all the time helping him with this
material she was good um
you know i thought that every character
was really interesting i thought the
story was interesting and it was just
like one of those like you know murder
mystery type type things too well you
know and it's also about family it's
also about like obligation and
and guilt and
and like you know how family like
you know they're in your life and
they're and they're just like you know
just mooching on you in and how you deal
with that and you know and what's your
obligation to do that you know uh
it just you know what i mean like it's
it was very it you know it's very like
even though it was this like high
profile thing you know about a high
profile person i think you can relate to
it
being like oh i have a cousin like this
i have a sister like this i have a
brother like this an uncle like this i
have someone in my life that's just like
you know you love them
you love them but they're not always
doing they're not always looking out for
your best interest you know and wesley
snipes did a fan he's such a he's a you
forget that wesley stubbs is actually a
great actor he really is i thought he
did a really great job in this movie i
think he's
aging well i think he's having a great
comeback from the tax problems and not
being like a superhero type guy anymore
just an older guy 50s 60s i'm not even
sure how old he is but he's i like these
roles i've seen him in recently i think
he's doing a great job he could be
really funny he could be really serious
you know you you didn't like him in this
movie
there were times when you liked him and
then there were times where you're like
oh man why would you do that so
i thought that this was uh it was well
done well made i do suggest you
uh watch it it's on netflix
it's like seven or eight episodes it's
actually it's really good in in like
and then oh there was like
what was the guy oh there was another
guy in it
you know it's about fans too like there
was this really this dude is like a fan
and he's like one of these kind of crazy
type
stalker fans you know just like yeah you
know it's like he you know kevin hart's
character like
changed his life because of you know
it's like those one of those fans it's
like you saved me i was at a dark time
and so the guy's following him all over
the place he's got like you know
memorabilia and he's got all this stuff
of the guy's career and he's you know
he's sweet but he's creepy you know and
like some stuff happens to him i mean
it's just it's it's like a lot of twists
and
um but it's uh really it's good i i do
recommend you watch this
thing it's true story
on
netflix
starring kevin hart and wesley snipes so
i give this one
i give this one
four woo-woo's
[Music]
so that one's a good i don't know how
many woo-woos that was but
it is what it is you guys get the idea
all right the next show i'd like to talk
about is
succession on hbo this is season is it
season three i'm not sure which is it
yeah this thing is i think it's season
three
man
[Music]
last night's episode
last night's episode is just like man
you know you think family's important
but man they cause a lot of stress in
your life
so this like there's this scene in last
night's episode man where
the father
kendall and and and and his dad or had
this like dinner
that you know kendall asked him to come
he's like buy me out you know i want to
i want to get away from you
and they just had this conversation that
was just like oh
like man this dad is a [ __ ] dude
you know what i mean oh
oh my god
so you really gotta watch that
ugh i mean this is so if you haven't
started watching succession i highly
recommend you know they're saying that
it's like they're saying that they say
this is sort of sort of based off
uh rob
rupert murdoch or whatever his name is
the the guy that owns fox news
you know it's like it's supposed to be
like his family like based off you know
a family like that
but you know you know this the stories
about this like high-profile family they
run a media conglomerate and you know
they're very concerned it's like
conservative media like fox news and
it's just about these
these brothers and sisters this family
that is just terrible
they are terrible people there isn't a
redeeming quality in any one of these
characters and then what's his name uh
culkin mccully culkin's little brother
is he's the best
like you hate him
he's he's such a disturbed
individual but such a great
character and then like the the the
daughter
the daughter's like you know
she's just the worst
you know what i mean she don't like her
husband you know she's just
she's just such an awful human being on
the show
and you just like i don't i don't even
know who you root for in this show and
then her husband the guy the english
actor he he's tom he's so funny and
quirky
you know and you just you feel for him
too like what are you doing like like
what are you doing around these people
oh then the guy playing kendall you know
i should have the website up so i can
like go through their names and tell you
who's who but it's like and then that
guy playing greg right there that guy
playing greg i'm pointing at him on for
you people listening but that guy oh his
character he's such a such a quirky
loser type character too man he wants to
sue greenpeace you know what i mean like
because it's because his grandfather's
giving his inheritance away like it's
like that kind of stuff it's just about
rich spoiled entitled people
who think the world revolves around them
and they just don't care about anyone
but themselves it is like the worst
family i've ever seen you know and then
like their mom who's divorced from the
dad she hates him and you know she's off
being terrible too
i mean
oh
man
i mean like i don't know how they pitch
this this show other than like it's like
we like watching rich people and like
this succession is basically a show
like if if you're a kind of person to
think rich people are terrible people
this is your show because they are
acting in a way that is the most
stereotypical thinking of what we think
is going on with rich white conservative
people
this is what we think of them the people
that made this show they have such
contempt for rich people
and they're showing it in this show and
so anything that you think like if you
think like oh man all they do is look
out for themselves all they do it's like
this is it and if you think like man if
you have money uh it leads to happiness
and then if you're one of those people
that are like no money can't lead to
happiness you watch succession and you
believe that because it's just like a
bunch of like terrible people being
terrible
you know that the dad is just like you
know the the worst kind of dad man you
could tell he was like like like the the
ex-wife said something really oh man and
it's about being like this last episode
is like such about terrible parenting
because like the mom is sitting with the
daughter and she's just basically saying
to her i shouldn't have had kids you
know she's like like imagine if your mom
or dad said that to you like i shouldn't
have had kids
she was like i should have had dogs
instead you know
you know and then she says like the
daughter's all like well dad wouldn't
want dogs
then the mom's like well your dad
what he would have done is he would have
kicked the dogs
just to see if they would come back
because that's what he does to people as
well and it was just like oh
ooh like i had so many moments in
yesterday's episode where i was like
damn
it's like oh i felt for these people and
that's why the show's great
that's why the show is great y'all so
i do highly suggest that you uh watch
succession i mean i give succession like
a lot of woo-woos
it's like it's like a really great show
and every single one of these people are
really doing a great job on the show
like the guy playing kendall man like
he's
i can't figure this guy out like i can't
even explain his character because like
if you saw last season he like
turned on his family and so now this
season he's like trying to be this sort
of like hero type guy or he's trying to
be like he's the good guy and everybody
else is the bad guy and you just see
like what a monster he really is
just a spoiled brat entitled [ __ ]
terrible dad to his kids
not a good
husband or not even a good boyfriend
terrible son shitty brother
and but you just like you feel for him
like the guy the actor is doing a
fantastic job
uh you know his style like he mumbles a
lot and he he like you could tell he's
like
he
he
he feels so unsure of himself but at the
same time sure of himself like the
performance is stellar
like i don't know i don't watch the
emmys and that kind of stuff anymore
because it's an echo chamber for liberal
nonsense so i don't watch the reward
shows anymore
you know it's just like you know what i
mean like it's just them being like you
know fix the world and it's just like
[ __ ] just give out awards okay like
what are you doing you don't do this at
a party but anyway i don't know if this
guy won an emmy but he should
you know the guy playing
yeah this guy playing kendall roy should
definitely
win an emmy because he's doing
a stellar job just an acting
clinic y'all just an acting clinic
so that's what i say about succession
and i get successions
[Music]
all right
all right guys
it's time to talk about
our sponsors from the show helix asleep
helix sleep
the best thing about them is they got
this sleep quiz that you take you know
it's like tinder
you know like you're doing like a
eharmony profile for yourself because it
matches your body type your sleeve
preference and it gives you the mattress
that's best for you i did that i'm a
side sleeper so i got this great
mattress it's not it's not too firm so i
can like sleep on my side it's not
hurting me
uh
you know it helped me with my back and
my sleep better i really enjoy this
mattress you know everybody's unique
that's the thing about you know and and
healing sleep knows this so they have
all different types you know if you
sleep on your back your stomach if you
move around all night it you know i mean
it's they got the mattress for you so if
you need a new mattress i do suggest
this and you don't got to go into like
some mattress store that's what this
sleep quiz is great
so if you're looking for a mattress like
i say take the quiz the shipping is free
and
and helix is awesome but don't even just
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com
griffin take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixfleet.com
griffin
start sleeping better
today y'all
okay
our next sponsor we got which i love is
express vpn
you know
you don't even realize with all these
cookies and and all the you know all the
website or all the tracking that they're
doing
um
it's ridiculous you know so i suggest
you getting a vpn get this express vpn
you know what's playing out right now at
big tech companies and social media
sites they're setting a dangerous
precedent you know it doesn't matter
your politics or who you voted for
everyone should have the right to
express themselves freely and sadly the
big tech monopoly has instead opted for
silencing tactics and censorship so to
fight back against this stuff and to
control your own internet you got to use
express
vpn when you use expressvpn app on your
computer or phone you
anonymously
can go to
the websites and stuff you can hide your
presence and your ip address and it
makes your activity more difficult to
trace
and sell to advertisers because that's
the sucky part you ever like go to a
thing and then all of a sudden like
some ads are popping up from things that
you went to and you're like hey what's
what's going on here and then it makes
you feel like uh is anything i'm looking
at private i want it to be private now
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it just takes one click to protect
all your devices that's why expressvpn
is rated number one by business insiders
so let's stop allowing big tech to
revoke our rights to free speech why not
revoke their right to your data instead
secure your internet with the vpn i
trust for online protection visit
expressvpn.com griffin that's
s v e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p n dot com slash
griffin to get extra three
three extra months free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
griffin right now to learn more
boom
look at me man get in the bag trying to
get this done
[Laughter]
um all right
okay last show that i want to get into
is another uh favorite show of mine
um let's get into it now wait let me
turn this off turn that off go here
boom it's dexter dexter
dexter new blood
oh
man so if you remember dexter back in
the day it was about
it's a dexter's a serial killer he works
for the police he works in forensics at
the police and he works with blood
and he had a tragic upbringing you know
he saw his mother being murdered and he
was in a pool of blood and he was
rescued by this guy who's a cop and the
guy figured out that dexter is a serial
killer
you know he realizes kid is going to be
a serial killer so he knew he couldn't
stop him from being a serial killer so
he taught him some rules
he taught him like only kill people that
deserve it you know so dexter and as an
adult he joins the police force so he
can investigate and he always finds out
who the most terrible people are that
got away with like the worst crimes and
he kills them and he like really knows
how to get away with it and you know so
it was like nine seasons of dexter you
know the last few seasons were like not
very good
you know what i mean like it was just
went a couple seasons too long
and then it was like they always had
like an other serial killers in and it
was like it was great though it was like
a really great series like the first
like few seasons of dexter
you know it was really good it was the
last two seasons that i was like ah but
i still watched it but it's a really
enjoyable uh show the dexter if you're
into that sort of stuff you know it's
dark you know it's rated r it's death
murder serial killing you know sex
intrigue it's all that kind of stuff you
get
so
now cut two since you know hollywood
can't make anything original you know
they're rebooting shows
but i gotta say this is a pretty good
reboot
uh so now cut to dexter it's now 10
years later dexter's living in some
small you know
rural town
in a snowy area where there's like
indian
reservation nearby
and he's now a new person he's
reinvented himself you know what i mean
he has a kid that he had to leave
because he didn't want the kid to be
around his dark passenger he likes to
call it so now he's living in this town
and
it's 10 years he hasn't killed anybody
in 10 years and his sister who was
murdered
you know because of his actions you know
she's kind of like his conscious his
conscience
and she's like in the show
and like like he's talking to himself
but he's talking to her you know so
she's there so that's good to see her
back on the show too because she was
great
i think she plays his i think that i
think they got divorced but in real life
they're actually married
they were married and now their brother
and sister in you know in the show
that's like what it was in the past i
believe that's what it was
um so
you know so now you cut to he's in this
town
and then like
you know of course he runs into
a bad person that did some bad stuff
and like oh he's like oh he has that
itch
and obviously you know
you have to know dexter's gonna murder
again and now it's just all about
what's going on you know
in this town how he's getting away with
it and the drama like you know his his
son shows up and you know he's trying to
figure out is his son a killer too and
you know what i mean like all this kind
of stuff so it's like it's actually
pretty good you know i wasn't sure if i
was going to like it but michael c hall
the guy that he's a great actor man you
know he's so interesting and
and he's doing a great performance and
the other people in the show are also
doing a great performance too and you
know and they've set it up good they've
set up this little town you know there's
like the bullies at the high school you
know it's a lot of like cliche stuff is
going on in the show too you know of
course there's like a guy who like is a
really rich guy he's the richest guy in
the area and you know he's doing bad
stuff to the environment and you know
the indian reservation hates him and of
course the sheriff's daughter is like
you know she's like one of these like
woke white white girls who's gonna
change the world you know so you have
that you know you have all those things
too but it's still well done it's well
acted it's well produced i'm like i say
i'm really enjoying
the show
so
i don't know if you guys
uh
i don't know if you guys
are into dexter but i do give dexter
some woo-woos i think like i said i
think they're doing a really great job
so woo-woo's to dexter i think i give
this 4 out of 5.
[Music]
so dexter y'all all right i guess we're
winding down this episode y'all i uh
let's go back to the holiday picture
let's get the holiday picture up
yeah um
[Music]
just randomly you know what i i play
warzone a lot i'm on eric griffin gaming
i'm gonna go on on there after this it's
eric griffin gaming on twitch if you
want to check me out you i could also
put videos up on on youtube eric griffin
gaming but uh i've been playing warzone
now for a you know all through the
pandemic i've been playing it and they
had this map the city is the fake city's
called verdance and tomorrow i believe
is the last day they got it finally got
a new map so i'm super excited about
that i think warzone is the best game
call of duty is the best game because
it's challenging it's always different
and that uh fight to be a battle royale
that you know that fight
of starting with 150 people and
whittling it down to one as the circle
closes is
such a fantastic gameplay
it's so challenging
frustrating i get all different types of
emotions when i play this game and i
love it so i'm really you know i'm gonna
be sad to see verdance i think i know
for dance more than i know los angeles
uh you know just all the little nooks
and crannies of the map so they got this
new map so shout out to them that's
still the best game i don't care what
anybody says call of duty warzone is
better than any other game okay
that's what i'm telling you right now
it's better than apex it's better than
uh pub g it's better than stupid
fortnite with the dumb building
call of duty is the best now
i didn't plan on doing this but let's do
it battlefield 2042 came out
epic fail
okay
epic fail you hear what i'm saying
like
they have these game the one the game
looks great it's beautiful the game the
the lightning in the sky and the the
change of the the
you know the clouds and and just how it
looks it's such a huge rich landscape
but the game modes are nothing there's
nothing to do
there's nothing exciting about it
there's no point to it you just you just
drop in and obviously you're just
running around trying to find people and
the maps are so big you barely run into
anybody
it's an epic fail hey ea or whoever
makes battlefield
stop trying to reinvent the wheel
and give us what we want there's a
reason that pubg
apex
fortnite and warzone call of duty are
the best games they're all battle royale
games
you're not smart enough to reinvent the
wheel just use the damn wheel okay
use the battle royale format
and
add your own little touches to it
fortnight got the dumb building apex is
like more cartoony and they have like
the little you know the all the little
all the different powers that people
have warzone has what it has you just
add your thing you keep trying to like
whoever the idiots are over there going
like oh here's what we're gonna do
everyone's gonna love this better than
the millions of people that are that
love the battle royale we're gonna show
them something different
it's an epic fail i actually want my
damn money back
how is a free game better than your game
this is what i want to know
i had to pay a hundred dollars for this
damn game and it sucks
and
every you know the war zone's free
free
like get your [ __ ] together man
they better come up with a battle royale
asap
because i'd play it
but like i tried to play these modes and
i'm like and then it's like it's just
boring multiplayer like even in call of
duty multiplayer is boring
but you play it because you're ranking
up your guns so you can use them in
rebirth island
uh what do you call it um
you know the the the battle royale or
the war zone battle royale
so that's why you you know there's a
purpose they have so many guns and
attachments and skins and you know you
do all these challenges so you can get
like you know it has to be a point a
purpose
if there's no purpose we don't want to
play
anyways
that's my
that's my
we'll just call that that's the bitching
with griffin segment for
this week y'all
uh yeah you know i gotta get i got some
more guests coming on and we'll start um
you know doing that but for now
thanks for watching riffing with griffin
y'all once again remember that i am on
twitch most days
uh eric griffin gaming on twitch make
sure you hit me with a follow and i'm
even this with this too man hit me with
a follow a subscribe hit the
notification so you know what's on hit
me with a like please share
let everybody know like you know i
appreciate all my loyal followers but
let's try to grow the damn show you know
this is like this is just me it's called
riffing with griffin sometimes i talk
about movies and music and sometimes i
talk about whatever's going on in the
world
you know it's just it is what it is we
out here riffle uh i gotta get back to
my real world advice from a grown ass
man i'ma do that too
uh that's i'll probably do that next
week uh so look out for that
and also guys have a safe wonderful
happy holidays
hanukkah just pass but happy hanukkah to
all the jews out there merry christmas
uh kwanzaa or whatever the hell you
celebrate if you don't celebrate
anything you know just be be well be
with your family during this time while
everybody else is with their family and
just try to enjoy life
and i appreciate you guys be safe out
there
um
yeah you know what
it's written griffin
[Music]
me
[Music]